hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Octodad I'm playing
this straight off the last episode so I
didn't get to see your responses hope
you guys enjoyed it and also I want to
point out it said that the dev time was
9 minutes and 5 seconds I'm calling
major on that because I would
love to see them do this anyway
this one says 8 minutes and 35 seconds
so it couldn't possibly be bad for me
ok so some sort of medical incident is
go this is a person my kids oh this is
the birth of my kids why am I in a
wrestling ring
why okay then why oh I gotta tell myself
to shut up now hello is it the nurse
station is this the nursing manual was
they even say safe say salty huh it's
salty arts I knew the book existed that
was from the last episode hooray nice
art on the walls okay I'm on in the
nurse I'm so excited I'm just skipping
with joy hello fellow nurse boy it's
good to be a nurse with all this medical
training and whatnot how you doing how
you doing friend how you doing you're
doing good that's right
hey okay so I need to find the patient
records hope up on there nurse Joanne
I'm a little busy okay so a good lady
lady geez someone's a little sassy today
alright so I need to go find tool 5 hi
hey hey screw you blooping all it's
gonna hurt in a second here
take some bloomin all straight into the
face you'll be fine in the morning what
is your weight just your bed do I have
to touch your bottom oh god I hope not
how do i okay all right
there here comes the frickin airplane
there's only gonna hurt the set ah big
windup YUM I'm gonna eat it myself okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god it's gonna kill me I can't
believe I'm still doing this 8:25 my
left nut octopi even have nuts just damn
melon I'll bring a book all right I'll
bring your salty arts low-key clipping a
little bit oh hi Susan
god damn it Susan it's good stuff
give me a hand I'm drowning here all
right
solty arts Jeremy stop staring at me
like that why don't you be helpful why
do I gotta get the bad patients this
look low to you what are you in pain
why are you even in this hospital all
right where's the IV bags over here yeah
it looks like it yep why am i listening
to the patient for diagnosis advice oh
yeah big whiny whiners just stupid IV
I'm sick of your face hope your face
gets sicker as a matter of fact screw
you and everyone you know have a nice
day Susan you got 205 he's a delight
hello and weird oh yeah I'm Shirley your
blood pressure's gonna answer all your
questions oh you keep asking them lady
oh no oh this can't be right you've got
exploding artery disease you're gonna
die 10 seconds flat
Oh
oh why would I do that ma'am
I'm gonna defer to my own professional
medical expertise because I made myself
lightheaded there for a little bit okay
just got it any minute now so okay I
have I could just not wrap this around
my head that would be beneficial to this
all righty
is that in your eye it's my face
blocking it all right whatever I told
you exploding artery disease no okay
this is you this is your P nor your P
nor is not there anymore I'll just be on
my way then that was not her P nor by
the way Susan are you even helping
anyone Susan hey hey baby
thank you lady are you trying to seduce
me I could never be seduced I'm a
married squid octopus whatever but I am
straddling your bed ever so seductive
okay I'm done fluffing your pillow so
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome also must I say that that says
hurts so good over there that's
hilarious
yes how do I turn it hello
how do I do this okay well did that I
just fluffed the pillar how many times
do I gotta fluff this pillar
get over here pillar I gotta stop
straddling it for just a minute okay
whoop alrighty then I'm fluffing it up
fluffing as hard as I can fluff
absolutely
what oh oh coming back okay thank you
ma'am I'll be back with your doughnuts
all right I'll get doughnuts but I blow
ok doughnuts are robo-moe doughnuts no I
didn't pick that yeah there we go
doughnuts
what what what no okay
that doesn't oh okay
did I hear you want some nuts you want
your light gone who the hell are you
anyway
are you the waiting receptionist yeah
okay I'm gonna get it eventually
yeah there's gonna be the most expensive
doughnuts ever doughnuts in a bag anyway
what are these doughnuts can I could I
please oh boy it's fun and once again
everything is done with me facing away
from it there we got to straddle it real
nice oh yeah oh this is a familiar
feeling okay I'll reach up deep inside
it there it is got it spilling done it's
everywhere I got your doughnuts lady a
nice doughnut lady you're not gonna have
a single damn doughnut left by the time
I get there
yep huh yep there you go you're so
welcome lady
I know I did I know I did is it an
emergency I'll seem to be a southern
octopod Akhter oh oh no oh no 205 oh no
[Music]
oh no I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
oh no okay hey y'all right there you're
right there y'all right buddy
we're gonna go on an adventure buddy
it's my new friend this is this is
helicopter man no this is he needs a
name rag doll Rick rag doll Rick and I
are gonna go for an adventure we need to
be alone for a little bit but you were
coming with me apparently Susan yeah oh
yeah this is an operating room over here
do I need to be here I can't be here yet
okay come along Rick all right Rick this
hang on for dear life I'm gonna get that
heart started with pure okay never mind
then Rick Rick Susan where you messin
with Rick Baron out I've been touching
my Rick you know how to feel like would
be able to touch my Rick Rick come along
baby we're gonna go all right I need to
get you cured apparently Rick just get
on the damn bed now on the bed Rick
Ricky I'll give you a ricky snack I'll
give you a Ruby snack I good enough
raises side flaps
nope that ain't right I need to be
actually in the room that would be
pretty helpful okay
oh that's cheer ya up one up you know
get rid of that get your butt all the
way on the bed that's an interesting
position you chose I definitely dad
nothing to do with that and we're good
get him to perform what oh we're going
for a ride Rick Rick we'll go for a ride
Ricky WikiWiki come on Rick come on
brick
Rick hey Rick come on this is fun me
busy whoa Nelly come on get get Rick
Rick Rick Rick classic Rick doesn't want
to go get his heart fixed every steps oh
man Rick we have a lot of laughs
gangway okay good this sure is a
fearsome challenge that I'm facing right
about now punks my brother can i okay
yep get that ah
boskie okay come along Rick I was a
little bit of a little bit of a
sidequest there but we're gonna go
forward into the prep room now I'm gonna
inject you with all kinds of stuff so
wash my hands I'm not a doctor I'm a
nurse why am i doing surgery now okay
anyway don't care it yeah boy yeah boy
okay wash hand wash one hand give a man
a Steph yeah hey Rick you want some
happy juice it's some good stuff maybe I
should give it to myself
a little drinking like a bottle inject
it into my big bulbous head thing all
right fine Rick you're right for it
we're good enough apparently let's go
you got your bloopin all you got your
stuff I'm gonna get you on the Oh our
table come with me Rick Rick let go
Rick Lego lag out done done you're done
okay
yeah a little-little ooh a little ooh I
don't know if this is for help
come back here Rick don't run away from
me okay
Rick just wreck get flat thank you page
dr. Nigel Oh dr. Nigel is this is this
is this this is this is a surgeon
simulator Octodad crossover bunk Bank oh
man
if you don't know dr. Nigel's the Nigel
from surgeon simular that's not Nigel
you're not nice oh I was expected a
giant hand just come bursting through
there I would have been so much more
interesting oh well okay how all right
then I guess I'm gonna go this way then
since dr. Nigel's being a bit of a
douche okay come on just go there's
gonna be a bear ain't it okay
excuse me doctor I I just had this
tender moment with you I don't know I
love you
okay doctor I've got him prepped ready
for the x-ray nothing else going on here
okay he's on the ground now wow wow this
is uh this safe right is safe safe
is it safe I'm going the wrong way save
all righty then
let's run him over with the damn thing
okay how about I get him to the x-ray
machine that might actually turn out a
little better
head up okay Matt all right a little
more little more little more just get
him a yeah well I looked bad
bring Nigel a scalpel oh it doesn't
matter that Rick's on the floor now
because have you no mind I don't mind
all right where am I going
where is the scalpel will a fork do no
that won't do how about this here you go
doctor oh sorry
Hey look at ty x-ray ty I got it that's
the first time man's get a scalpel
scalpel scalpel
oh that looks like scalpel Lee traveling
by x-ray machine Frick got my face here
you go
hope you like that organized all a bone
saw how much more crab do you need okay
yeah all righty then in a box
Oh medical waste
ah got it
hahaha what happens if I just inject the
poor doctor with all of his crap
[Music]
okay all right then okay then
beep boop what this doesn't seem right
where's all the blood
what hand Nigel a tool here uh this will
do right there you go
uh how about this one that'll work go
for it baby
what are you doing all right then
good job Nigel keep at it you almost get
him
Yeah right over the heart honk bonk bonk
okay looking good Nigel looking good
looking real good looking real good
you're a genius doctor I admire you so
much in so many ways
but we can never be I hope you know that
yep yeah okay I'm getting it it's a
little finicky doctor you just gonna
have to be patient with me okay get guy
okay we'll go down there parent oh god
if I can stop waving my arms like I just
don't care okay there we go all done
right no one more help
yeah all right we're done right go
together gumdrops wipe Nigel for it you
got it doctor I always enjoy these time
son I'm able to be so close to you oh
you like that
[Music]
Cass at heart the heart go oh god my leg
okay how oh how am i 8 minutes and 35
seconds is a goddamn lie Nigel whoa
Nelly whoa Nelly whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
well having a bit okay there we go Oh
God aah tedious tedious tedious it is
this is my name
grab a loo hair Lilu okay
[Music]
okay yeah but Oh Bo Bo Bo Bo Shiba yeah
big boy you bouquet
where'd that last one go yeah where'd it
go
not over here I think I saw maybe over
there
he'll die I'd like good but do anything
no that was a plant whoo nice painting
wait no was it aha it was hiding it was
hiding I knew it I did it I did it good
what's that doing haha okay I'll get
ready for it feel good one more time
sorry I'm just gonna get this ready yeah
baby yeah okay
all right then good good enough I'll
just take the patient back home to his
loving family the one that I love so
much got along Rick yeah okay if I could
stop um about that I'm gonna go with I
hate this guy now Rick's okay
Rick's okay when he just shuts up okay
here we go Rick
come on baby we're gonna go on an
adventure
[Music]
Oh Susan could you help me please Thank
You Susan
you're a delight I hate you good here
y'all Rick back oh god why Jeff Cobb
[Music]
tada
done and well alright then if we're able
to pull random stories out of our but I
guess it's gonna be okay that was
awesome
and weird so anyway that's all this
shorts for now but I know that they're
gonna be making more in the future so I
hope you guys enjoy this check out the
full Octodad playlist over there in the
description below and check out some
other cool stuff with octave dad
somewhere in the Internet
I don't know enjoy yourselves have fun
on YouTube it's a free day go have fun
gonna thank you outlet we thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video you're
gonna die
[Music]
uh-huh do you mind if I dance while we
talk pans mode move the mouse to move
the arm and he to move the camera while
holding the right mouse button or ctrl
left move the mouse forward and back
we'll raise and lower the arm whoa